et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vincent maréchal professeur à la
sorbonne universités science spécialiste
en virologie
bonsoir professeur maréchal merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france parce qu'évidemment on a
beaucoup de questions vous posez tout
d'abord ces deux cas confirmé dans notre
pays qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous dit
aux français il faut les rassurer au
contraire est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
je pense que le fait qu'on soit en
mesure de détecter avec une telle
efficacité des cas doit être pris comme
un message d' alerte il ya quelque chose
qui se passe je crois qu on en est tous
conscient maintenant pu presque presque
un mois et demi mais le message positif
c'est qu'on a les outils on à
l'infrastructure on a les compétences
dans nos hôpitaux on a les compétences
dans les laboratoires pour effectuer
très rapidement un diagnostic de
certitude ce qui veut dire que très
rapidement contrairement peut-être à
d'autres pays dans le monde on est en
mesure d'identifier les cas de les
isoler de prendre des mesures qui évite
la propagation du virus en croit qu'on
est vraiment dans une phase aujourd'hui
où les outils où le maillage
épidémiologique qu'on a le maillage de
surveillance est tellement efficace
effectivement que pour l'instant on
détecte les cas isolé dans les deux cas
j'ai pas le temps de m'enseigner en
détail sur la nature des deux cas mais
de toute évidence viennent de régions
dans lesquelles
on a des foyers infectieux c'est pas un
écart très étonnant ce qu'on arrive
alors j'ai entendu parler d'un cas qui
dit non mardi une patiente qui viendrait
de chine situés à paris et en auvergne
effectivement des patients qui viennent
de judo ce ne sont pas des cas atypique
dans la dans la lah dans
l'identification fédéral à qui l'on doit
gagner on exactement viennent de régions
en conservant on sait qui a des
problèmes ce que vous nous dites pour
bien comprendre le message c'est que
voilà l'épidémie peut arriver elle
arrive d'ailleurs en 2006 mais on est
paré en france on est prêt à l'affronter
jeu ce que je dis c'est que ça c'est un
constat qu'on fait dans plusieurs pays
la formation scientifique a circulé
relativement rapidement alors on peut
toujours discuter sur le retard qui a eu
en chine à faire part de la situation
il ya une excellente coopération à
l'échelle internationale ça faut que les
gens en aient conscience c'est à dire
que les chercheurs les médecins ne sont
pas isolés dans les différents pays une
circulation et un partage de
l'information scientifique qui est fait
de façon très très très efficaces ce qui
a permis très rapidement très
transparent et ça c'est vraiment une
notion essentielle ce qui a permis très
rapidement de développer des tests pour
détecter de façon spécifique les gens
qui sont infectés ce qui veut dire très
rapidement qu'on peut les isoler et donc
ça c'est important lorsqu'on voit
également en france et que on a eu des
crises précédemment il ya eu la grippe
aviaire pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
la grippe h1n1
on a eu ailleurs dans le monde les
épidémies 10 k et c'est donc on a on est
dans des situations dans lesquelles on
sait que ce risque infectieux existe on
sait que c'est une maladie qu'on appelle
des maladies émergentes risquent de
revenir avec une fréquence qui est qui
n'est pas négligeable
on parle de deux maladies qui pourraient
revenir tous les deux trois ans on est
prévenu on a donc des plans de gestion
sanitaire qui sont relativement efficace
on voit où il fonctionne relativement
bien aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a aussi
une mise en place d'un réseau dans les
hôpitaux qui est qui et prépositionné
qui est peu développée en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie dont je pense
qu'on est plutôt bien préparé je suis
plus inquiet pour les pays aujourd'hui
qui ne déclaraient pas de calais sa
tendance qui on vous dit on est bien
préparé on entend beaucoup voilà il ya
conflit social évidemment en france que
vous n'ignorez pas les urgences qui
manquent de lits est ce qu'on aurait le
cas échéant suffisamment de lits
notamment en réanimation parce qu'on a
vu que c'était un petit peu le problème
de cette maladie dans un second temps en
tout cas quand on arrive et je pense
qu'il faut pas projeter la situation
chinoise le nombre de cas observés en
chine à ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui dans une situation où vous
voyez on en est à quelques cas qu'on
détecte on isole immédiatement donc je
ne suis pas spécialiste de la question
et ça je pense que c'est une question à
poser plutôt de la santé ou collègues
qui gère les hôpitaux il ya un message d
alerte je pense qu'il faut aussi répété
que les médecins sont excessivement
sensibilisés à la question que les
personnels soignants sensibilisés à la
question que la communication vous
faites journalistes médias sur cette
question là et essentiel je crois qu'il
s'agit pas d'affoler les gens mais
plutôt de faire comprendre que si on
communique beaucoup c'est aussi pour que
les gens soient sensibilisés à cette
question prennent des mesures
préventives
vous revenez on l'a dit oui ou un vous
revenez d'une zone à risque est bien
plutôt que d'aller prendre le métro si
vous avez un doute vous restez à la
maison
vous mettez en quarantaine on l'a des
messages sont passés notamment pour les
gens revenant de l'italie dans les zones
à risque on ne passe la période
d'incubation et d'en-cas doute en cas
d'apparition de signes cliniques ont
fait le 15
et on a déjà en phase qui vous répondent
alors des questions précises sait
combien la période d'incubation s'est
emparé de 14 jours on a rappelé heures
si vous visez 27 jours alors oui alors
il ya il y as on affine les données au
fur et à mesure de l'évolution de la
maladie
on a les données chinoises compter les
premières connecté on a des collègues
qui travaillent un peu partout dans
l'eau sur cette question là donc les
chiffres sa fille donc il faut pas
s'étonner à ce que l'on revoit au fil de
l'eau à sa ronde de notions aujourd'hui
ce qui a l'air d'être globalement
acceptée c'est que l'incubation est de
l'ordre de 14 jours et effectivement il
ya un cas qui a été d'écrire en chine
je crois d'un patient donc il est
vraisemblable ou en tout cas il est
affirmé qu'il aurait été infecté qu'il
aurait déclenché et signe 27 jours plus
tard il est possible effectivement qui
est une extension de l'incubation à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on sait que c'est
14 jours c'est quand même les chiffres
qu'on observe le plus fréquemment on
entendait dire le chef de l' oms en
chine hier la le monde n'est pas prêt
pourquoi cette maladie fait elle aussi
peur c'est parce qu'on ne la connais pas
assez bien alors il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord c'est une maladie qui est baky
qui frappe l'imaginaire c'est comme une
maladie est associé à une mortalité qui
moindre que celle du strass qu'on a
connue en 2003 qui était de l'ordre de
10 % de mortalité l'orne à 2%
pour mémoire une grippe hivernale c'est
0 1% donc c'est 20 fois plus mortelle
que la grippe hivernale qu'on me coupe
qu'on connaît bien
il ya 7 via ce caractère là il ya la
vitesse de dissémination qui quoi qu'on
en dise est assez spectaculaire et ça
c'est lié à ces virus qui sont transmis
par voie aérienne par voie respiratoire
donc on a un tableau qui est un tableau
qui inquiète avec une maladie qui
circule très très vite et ça je crois
que c'est le constat aussi d'un monde
dans lequel les communications sont très
ouvertes et donc les marchandises
circulent les personnes circulent les
pathogènes et lady recul les virus
circulent également
est-ce que vous pensez que l'épidémie
risque vraiment d'augmenter se
transformer en pandémie il faudrait
activé ce plan pandémie ceux là
il ya une croix qu'il faut il faut dire
les choses clairement la notion de
pandémie est une épidémie qu'on décrète
d'ampleur d'amplitude mondial donc un
des critères qui sont d'ailleurs pas
forcément partagé par tous pour dire
qu'à partir d'une épidémie qui se
déclare sur plusieurs continents on est
on est à une échelle pandémique ce qu'il
faut que les gens comprennent également
c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on passe
d'un stade épidémique est un stade
pandémique qui ne surent épidémiologique
qu'on a une gravité de l'infection qui
est plus importante le virus sont là on
est en train de parler d'un virus car
sans doute peu évolué ça surprend mais
c'est comme ça c'est un gosse qui a peu
évolué et qui ne gagne pas non plus en
pathogénicité c'est juste extension de
la pathologie qui passe dans une zone
régionale voix de plusieurs zones
régionales à une zone beaucoup plus
élargie à quoi doit-on s'attendre
il y aura un public on dit voilà avec la
chaleur ça va tendre à disparaître est
ce que ce sont là des bruits de couloir
pouvoir c'est parce qu'on cherche des
références dans les virus qu'on l'a déjà
dans nos tiroirs où on fréquente le
virus qui ressemble le plus et vous
voyez bien dans l'actualité auxquels on
fait le plus référence à virus grippal
on sait que le virus grippal circule
dans les pays au moment des périodes
humides des périodes froides et l'on
sait qu effectivement balala la période
grippale s'arrête au printemps et
reprend l'année d'après pendant l'hiver
et donc j'ai thibault de l'iba le modèle
gris pâle et peut-être pas si loin que
ça du modèle coronavirus parce que
coronavirus partagent un certain nombre
de propriétés mais n'est pas identique
du tout virus de la grippe à un partage
peut-être des propriétés communes donc
on peut faire ce type de projection
on n'est pas sûr aujourd'hui il faut
évaluer la résistance du virus à aux
conditions environnementales à la
sécheresse à la chaleur et tout ça on
les ondes c'est des données qu'on aura
un jour ou l'autre ces données on est en
train d'essayer d'acquérir dans les
laboratoires qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
faire
on va s'en sortir vaccin est en cours on
imagine d'élaboration les recherches en
tout cas sont des roches est là encore
une fois faut voir qu'on est allé très
très vite falala le monde scientifique
et le monde médical ont réagi très vite
on est sur une épidémie quand même qui
démarre en décembre janvier
dès janvier on isole le virus donc ce
qui était une des étapes essentielles
pour construire un test diagnostique
l'institut pasteur noté greg on
travaille très efficacement et très
rapidement pu isoler le virus construire
un tel diagnostic et le virus
l'obtention du virus est une étape
préalable à tester dans les molécules
qu'on a dans nos laboratoires dans l'eau
pharmacopée des molécules antivirales
donc dès qu'on peut cultiver le virus en
laboratoire ou peu commencé à cribler
des molécules et voir si on a pas déjà
quelque chose et puis l'obtention du
virus était une étape très importante
également pour procéder à la fabrication
d'un vaccin
néanmoins un vaccin est en période où
tout va bien il ya une vague en france
en particulier ont contrôlé vaccin on
s'inquiète d'une injection l'utilisation
des vaccins
un vaccin c'est quelque chose qu'on a
aussi testé où il faut s'assurer avant
de la ministre à grande échelle qui a
pas de risque sanitaire
alem d'administrer le vaccin dont il ya
des étapes à franchir
il faut tout un réseau industriel qui
soit structuré qui puisse produire
suffisamment de doses et ça aujourd'hui
on sait le faire pour la grippe par
exemple ce que chaque année on a un
nouveau vaccin pour le coronavirus tout
système là n'est pas encore en place
mais il est vraisemblable qu'on puisse
le faire alors donner des délais
aujourd'hui c'est pour moi c'est juste
pas possible je travaille pas sur le
sujet il faudra aller voir les
spécialistes et les gens dans leurs
laboratoires
on espérait être un peu rassuré mais en
tout cas vous voyez on a les outils pour
le faire mais merci en tout cas pour
vous avez des données des explications
très claires même si beaucoup plus avec
mon professeur vincent maréchal merci à
merci hong kong